[Music]
yeah all right worse when you talk about
not talking right yeah that's for your
time that was hard
all right so with reptile you'll notice
that a lot of this returning moves
he's got the forty ball which he has a
fast one and yes he also which is pretty
pretty cool with this I just got the
slide I'm get returning he is in the
edge slide which is a lot faster at full
screen and has armor he's got a spit of
course that returns but you can exit and
I actually a pool of essence which does
like damage over time while you're in it
he has a new overhead claw and the
return of the - the the Zippy speedy run
right she also has that other it also
has that yeah he has that crossing all
variations and what's also great about
it is the e^x Persians all right there
we go
is uh he gets versions doop opposite so
you can extend their combos off of those
as well so you can do and then follow up
with slide or whatnot but regardless is
that you can pretty much add that two
and one into almost anything near burn
it and do it okay a really useful up a
lot of this posted things right and then
you can actually stop the ball that
Tyler just walked in sorry
yeah to create a just cage your opponent
what are you gonna do Tyler what are you
gonna do jump oh yeah that's what he's
gonna do and that's across all
variations and then he actually has
expiration to each one of them so I must
go that long and the Sinovel is super
slow right and so that's pretty much a
lot of his common moves what's great
about reptile is his combos for the most
part don't change cross level variations
so if you learn his main combo strings
it carries over across all variations
and its main change what you want to
utilize it
so with deceptive he can do it so if you
hold the button down he'll go completely
invisible if you just do the the normal
attack you'll actually just see like the
silhouette of it just like that and if
you hold it down he'll go completely
invisible or if you do the e.x version
he'll go in business then it's where am
i Tyler and so what should I know wait
till you want to be able to do it later
I will I'm pretty sure right well so
that's basically what he has for
deceptive alright so we'll move on to
what I like to call the stinky variation
and you'll notice even on the players
life that he has a gas cloud surround
him the little bugs little quick meal if
he gets hungry dirty battle is always
traveling with food always food here's
the reptilian boy scout always prepared
[Music]
all right so now I go noticed that he
has this gas around him as you're
standing right next to me you're taking
damage right so if I'm doing combos and
you're close to me or I do a throw
you're gonna take that additional damage
just because of this very it never goes
away never goes away
I use Obie's gas then of course he can
do a normal command for it which creates
a larger cloud that does more damage and
you can do the X version which is like
his entire body is a giant wasa help
it's just [ __ ] yeah so you knocked me
down stand above me with that going what
are using getting or get you into a
corner and just do some corner combo is
letting it and that's that's on top of
the the acid pool so why can't you
getting double the damage and all the
fun yeah double very dangerous in corner
yes definitely so that that's the main
difference for this variation because he
has so many special moves that it's all
variations right and so many of them
launch it really set up combos and so
many options so let's go to our final
variation it's actually something I like
about them if you are a little
intimidated by the all the variations
that these characters have to learn
Thomas free throw tells a good character
saying well I'm gonna learn this one
character and I have a stable of tools
that I have access to their will but
like my character is the same and I can
still you know get really what will work
differently
exactly absolutely dude and you'll
notice that I have a nice little snake
belt I like to dress up in my nimble
stance or variation hashtags think bill
has text does that arrange this we must
first artist you're straight and reptile
want to work together interesting
interesting finishes happening so with
the nimble this is I'm gonna say it's
probably my favorite one is this just oh
no I'm here I am naturally just dropping
average you don't even have to tell
that's only ten study yeah so he can
continue bouncing your belly yeah right
right
he gets faster the opponent gets slower
it's like he's using his heightened
agility and enhanced senses to control
the battle - yeah that's exactly what I
was gonna say yeah yeah exactly
so with that naturally you can do a
whole bunch of different setups and
combos that normally would not connect
man that variation and when you have
that active will yeah that was like a
comedy yeah that guy so that one
normally can't come off of it but if you
have the Titans agility you can actually
continue a combo off of that so that
that for the most part is the main
differences in each of reptiles
variations there's kind of the
accelerated versions they're sure it and
they know and you know I'll play it very
differently you have to play you know
there'll be some that might be too
technical shop some that are using for
others it's available there's a lot of
variation there for how you play as a
player or your skill level which is good
like I think reptiles a character that
we played by a lot of players